chers collègues mesdames messieurs
l'autre discussions d'aujourd'hui avec
madame la chancelière d'allemagne
se sont déroulés traditionnellement de
façon tout à fait satisfaisante
avec la délégation nous avons traité en
détail de l'évolution et des
perspectives de la coopération russo
allemande nous avons traité d'un certain
nombre de questions et comme vous le
savez
un le caractère particulier de cette
visite et que après les élections
législatives en allemagne madame merkel
s'apprête à quitter son poste de
chancelière et je tiens à dire que nous
serons de toute façon toujours heureux
de l'accueillir ici en russie en russie
comme hôte particulière
et pendant 16 ans madame merkel a dirigé
le gouvernement allemand
est il s'agit d'un des plus grands pays
d'europe et elle est une des personnes
les plus respectés dans le monde
nous avons établi avec l d'excellentes
relations commerciales politiques nous
avons toujours été en contact nous avons
discuté des différents aspects des
questions bilatérales nous avons encore
donné nos actions sur la politique
internationale bien entendu nos points
de vue ont parfois diverger mais nous
avons toujours plus de façon ouverte et
franche pour trouver des compromis sur
les questions les plus complexes et je
le souligne l'allemagne est pour la
russie est un des partenaires
prioritaires sur le plan politique comme
sur le plan économique et quand on parle
des échanges économiques entre la russie
et l'allemagne malgré les le coup franc
a porté porté par le coronavirus
les échanges se maintiennent et malgré
une baisse après une baisse le volume de
ces échanges reprend et avec 33 %
d'augmentation cette année pour plus de
21 milliards d'euros
et
en 2020 2021
se déroulent les années croisées entre
la russie l'allemagne sur le plan
économique et un certain nombre de
rencontres ont été organisées
et nos milieux d'affaires participent de
façon active à tous ces échanges à
toutes ces discussions
cela concerne des projets en matière
économique en matière agricole
et vous savez que nous avons aussi de
grands projets très connue de tout le
monde et qui sont en cours de
réalisation et nous espérons bien que le
plus grand d'entre eux n'est pas le
dernier bien entendu aujourd'hui nous
avons abordé un certain nombre de
questions de l'actualité internationale
notamment avec les événements actuels
d'afghanistan
et cela est évidemment une question
prioritaire actuellement
on a vu que le mouvement des talibans
contrôlent quasiment la totalité du
territoire y compris la capitale et
compte tenu de ces faits il faut
analyser et étudier
les possibilités d'éviter un
effondrement de l'état afghan
et éviter en même temps
les jeux venant de l'extérieur pouvant
se dérouler sur le pays notamment en
cherchant à imposer la démocratie
selon des principes qui ne correspondent
pas aux réalités aux traditions
religieuses politiques et ethniques du
pays nous connaissons l'afghanistan nous
ne connaissons bien et nous savons
comment se payer construit et nous
savons
à quel point des modes des modalités
externe peuvent être inadapté à ce pays
et les tentatives en la matière n'ont
jamais été réussi dans ce pays et ne
font que provoquer des dégradations en
même temps nous voyons que l'état les
dents en met fin au combat qu'ils ont
commencé à rétablir l'ordre public et
assurer la sécurité des habitants des
missions diplomatiques et j'espère que
tout cela va se concrétiser ce processus
doit être suivi par la communauté
internationale de façon coordonnée sous
l'égide de du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu autre point il nous paraît
important d'éviter la pénétration de
deux terroristes de tout poil sur dans
les organes de l'état en afghanistan
parmi les autres sujets internationaux
nous avons abordé la question du
règlement dans le sud est de l'ukraine
je sais que madame merkel a fait
beaucoup pour essayer de résoudre cette
crise elle était à la source du format
dit normandie et elle a aussi cherché
des solutions pour restaurer la paix
dans cette région et malheureusement
pour l'instant il n'y a pas eu de
résultats positifs aujourd'hui nous
avons fait part de nos préoccupations
quant au conflit sur la ligne de contact
et ces discussions vont être très
prochainement poursuivi
depuis le début du mois il ya eu plus de
mille infractions à
cesser le feu et des localités ont été
ont fait l'objet de frappes d'artillerie
on voit un certain nombre de
propositions qui sont faites et qui vont
à l'encontre des principes
du désaccord de minsk et par conséquent
encore une fois nous demandons à madame
la chancelière
notamment compte tenu de sa visite et
qu'elle va voir maintenant à kiev 2-2
d'inviter les ukrainiens à respecter
leurs engagements liés aux accords de
minsk nous considérons
que les contradictions internes de la
société vis l'origine ne peuvent se
faire que dans le cadre de la
législation et entre les biélorusses eux
mêmes ils sans intrusion externe de
l'extérieur
nous avons parlé aussi
de la question du nucléaire iranien et
avait après la formation du nouveau
gouvernement iranien nous espérons que
le plan de l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien de 2015 pour être poursuivi nous
avons parlé d'ailleurs je me suis
entretenu récemment par téléphone avec
le nouveau président iranien avec madame
merkel nous sommes bien d'accord sur la
nécessité aussi de trouver un accord
pour le règlement en libye et votre
humble serviteur participé l'an dernier
aux discussions de la conférence de
berlin visant à améliorer la situation
sur le terrain aujourd'hui nous espérons
que la communauté internationale
va faire en sorte que l'ensemble des
parties en conflit puisse discuter et
développer les points positifs qui
pour l'instant
n'ont pas encore été
trouver
nous avons également parlé de la
situation en syrie
sur l'ensemble sur la majorité du
territoire le cessez le feu se maintient
plus ou moins mais il reste une menace
terroriste
et en raison des sanctions illégales
prononcée contre damas et de la pandémie
on voit toujours un certain nombre de
problématiques
la résolution
25,85 du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
a permis après les discussions qui ont
été menées à genève de trouver un
certain nombre de choses et nous
espérons que les pays européens devaient
ainsi que notamment l'allemagne
permettront de d'apporter une aide au
peuple syrien encore une fois je tiens à
remercier
madame merkel pour le travail qu à
conques elle accomplit pas seulement
dans la rencontre aujourd'hui mais
toutes ces années passées je le répète
je ne serons toujours heureux
d'accueillir en russie madame angela
merkel je vous remercie
[Musique]
dingue et asseoir ses cornes et la
chine rigging 16e
prix
comme en
ce qui concerne les relations
bilatérales
et ces relations ce caractère et nous
avons les moments positifs que je
voudrais écolo qu'est évoqué notamment
les relations économiques
et le rôle de l'allemagne pour la russie
que le président vient de mentionner
ce rôle est due aux initiatives
économiques ou à des milliers des stages
qui permettent aux jeunes russes de
d'abord de passer des stages dans les
entreprises allemandes ce sont des
relations qui font chaud au coeur
mais nous savons qu'il y à une situation
assez désagréable au tour d'alexis
navalni il a été condamné il se retrouve
en prison suite à la décision du
tribunal qui en conformité avec
le conseil européen de droits de l'homme
est une chose inadmissible
donc j'ai exprimé mon opinion là dessus
et je réclame la libération d'alexis
navalni j'ai souligné que nous allons
suivre avec attention cette affaire dans
l'avenir nous sommes mécontents par le
fait que les que trois ans jai ho
allemandes font partis des listes
font partie de la liste des
organisations en désirable en grand de
travail a été mené dans le cadre du
dialogue
de saint pétersbourg dans le cadre de la
coopération
des sociétés civiles
je voudrais savoir si nous pouvons
continuer à travailler dans ce sens et
exclure ces organisations des listes des
organisations
indésirables
et donc nous avons également évoqué le
sujet du nord stream de ce n'est pas un
projet bilatéral entre la russie et
l'allemagne mais cet angle projet qui
relève d'un caractère européen parce
qu'il réunit les entreprises des autres
pays également dans ce contexte là nous
avons évoqué le document
signé entre les états unis et
l'allemagne
et nous avons à traiter avec le
président
des faits de fait que
le négociateur sur le transit du gaz via
l'ukraine est une personne très
expérimenté
ce sera le sujet a pris 2021 nous sommes
responsables en quelque sorte de cela il
faut tenir compte de certains aspects
économiques nous avons dans ce contexte
là à discuter des relations russie eu
nous avons appris que le projet le
paquet climatique
compte tenu du règlement
transfrontalier des
hydrocarbures
nous voyons cette envie
de développer ce projet et je partage
cette idée le sujet de l'afghanistan a
joué un rôle clé également dans des
négociations j'ai souligné que
évidemment c'est un moment très
déprimant
le fait que les talibans sont revenus
dans le pays et se sont emparés du son
territoire mais c'est un fait et j'ai
informé le président de notre opinion et
selon l'ana mon avis notre priorité
maintenant c'est d'aider les gens qui
ont pendant des années travailler dans
le pays qui ont une coopération avec
l'allemagne elle nous sommes prêts à
leur donner asile en allemagne nous
sommes prêts à les faire sortir du pays
dans l'est les meilleurs délais
j'ai demandé le parti russe
d'évoquer le sujet humanitaire dans
leurs négociations avec les talibans
notamment du côté de l'onu en
afghanistan il faut assurer la livraison
d aide humanitaire
un autre allié les gens qui nous ont
aidés
à la police fédérale ces personnes là
doivent avoir une opportunité de quitter
l'afghanistan
nous avons également évoqué la question
et craignent end le format mouvement
c'est le seul format que non postaux
pour l'instant et les sujets
controversés
ils sont discutés à présent nous voyons
qu'il n'y a pas de dynamique apportée à
présent malheureusement à
des militaires ukrainien périssent sur
la ligne de contact je voudrais donner
plus de vie à ce format la dernière
réunion a eu lieu en 2019 à paris ils
les objectifs que nous nous sommes fixés
à paris
par des séparatistes dans la
région de donetsk et de lougansk
dans le cren de l'autre côté donc nos
objectifs ont été fixés et je souligne
que nous sommes prêts
à atteindre plus de progrès dans ce sens
pour défendre les intérêts des résidents
de l'ukraine pour que tout le monde
puisse vivre d'une manière paisible en
ukraine et c'est notre position actuelle
l'annexion de la crimée à notre avis
c'est une violation de l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine
nous allons défendre cette position
évidemment
je vais me prononcer pour
l'intégrité territoriale de la craie de
l'ukraine
en ce qui concerne la biélorussie et
j'ai condamné
[Musique]
l'application
des personnes qui sont en péril et un
temps qu'une arme hybride je parle
notamment de la situation sur la
frontière entre la biélorussie et la
lituanie nous avons évoqué au également
les situation en syrie en libye pour ce
qui est de la libye il est nécessaire de
mettre en oeuvre les résultats de la
conférence
allemande il faut faire sortir des
mercenaires étrangères du pays de l'est
libe il faut donner aux forces libyennes
la possibilité de
rendre réel lorsque leurs idées sur
l'avenir de la libye
l'allemagne et la russie ont des points
communs là dessus
nous avons également parlé des défis
des
intempéries qu'a connu la russie
surtout en sibérie et
surtout dans le nord le pôle erp la
région polaire
nous sommes persuadés qu'il faut lutter
contre les changements climatiques et
pour cela nous avons besoin d'une
coopération
responsable
ça concerne d'autres questions également
depuis 16 ans j'ai visité la russie
cette fois je crois donc j'ai eu des
contacts réguliers avec la russie les
négociations ne se sont pas toujours
déroulée facilement il ya eu des moments
controversé mais j'ai toujours essayé de
chercher un compromis
dans le contexte international
on ne peut pas avoir d' alternative
rationnelle en dialogue en échange des
arguments
on doit se fixer des tâches ambitieuse
tout aurait pu être simple mais il faut
toujours continuer à le dialogue et
merci chaque collègue dans le dans le
cadre de cette conférence de presse vous
pouvons pas passer poser deux questions
de chaque partie alors à nos invités
vous avez les paroles
merci madame la chancelière
vous avez dit qu'aujourd'hui lors des
négociations vous avez défendu la cause
d' alex et navalni de sa libération et
le président poutine c'est la question
pour vous qu'est ce qu'il faut pour
libérer alexeï navalni et qu'est ce
qu'il faut pour mettre fin aux
poursuites de ceux qui défendent à
l'excès navalni et ma question pour les
deux pour les
aujourd'hui c'est l'anniversaire de la
tentative de me pose une mandale excès
de manille il a publié un article où il
réclame la lutte il appelle à la lutte
contre la corruption parce que la
corruption est la racine de tous les
maux de notre terre que pensez vous de
cette proposition monsieur poutine
par exemple ils exigent les sanctions
des oeufs contre les oligarques et de
votre entourage
en ce qui concerne la personne dont vous
avez parlé il n'a pas été condamné pour
son activité politique mais pour des
infractions des actes criminels à
l'égard de partenaires étrangers
en ce qui concerne son activité
politique
je pense que personne ne doit se cacher
derrière des arts et des activités
politiques pour mener une activité qui
est criminel deuxième point en ce qui
concerne l'opposition non systémiques
dans l'ensemble
je ne vois pas vraiment que dans les
pays occidentaux en europe
s'étaient unis par exemple le mouvement
des gilets jaunes en france que ces
personnes aient été
particulièrement soutenue
par les organes législatifs des pays
lors de leur confrontation avec eux la
police est par exemple dans le cas du
congrès aux etats unis
avec
plus de 100 enquête sans enquêtes
pénales ont été ouvertes contre les
participants à la prise du capitole
il y a eu des peines très très lourd de
15 ans en 25 ans de prison donc je pense
qu'il faut être objectif d'une manière
générale et prêter attention également à
cet aspect du problème en ce qui nous
concerne
on a notre système politique qui se
développent et tous les citoyens de la
fédération de russie ont le droit
d'exprimer leurs opinions politiques
de former des organisations politiques
de participer aux élections mais cela
doit se faire dans le cadre de la
constitution et de la législation en
vigueur nous ferons tout pour que la
situation en russie soit stable
prévisible
la russie a suffisamment connu deux
révolutions en russie au 20e siècle on
n'a pas envie d'avoir d'autres
révolutions et j'espère que l'évolution
va se poursuivre ainsi
en ce qui concerne les décisions de
justice en en fédération de russie nous
demandons de respecter ses décisions qui
sont prises oui la lutte contre la
corruption est une chose importante mais
elle ne doit pas s'en être utilisé comme
argument politique nous savons très bien
et vous savez très bien que cet outil
est utilisé dans des certains objectifs
politiques et et que c'est même
conseillé de l'utiliser pour parvenir à
certains résultats politiques
et c'est à dire que certains qui dirige
les gens qui sont impliqués dans cette
lutte le savent très bien mais bien
entendu la lutte contre la corruption
est important nous accordons une grande
importance à ce point et nous ferons
tout pour éradiquer ce phénomène de la
façon la plus étendue possible
je voudrais également souligner que
nous avons parlé en détail de comment
nous voyons les systèmes politiques de
la liberté des activités politiques je
pense que la question d'un beau system
système de gouvernement et la lutte
contre la corruption sont liés et donc
l'exigence ce dec cinéma ni pour l
élargir des sanctions est importante
aujourd'hui à dans l'union européenne et
les sanctions
sont liées au contexte
justement il y a il faut avoir des faits
la corruption économique et les saints
et les sanctions c'est ce n'est pas si
facile de les réunir dû boire un lien
mais nous avons discuté de ces questions
parce que la corruption et les activités
politiques sont vraiment à
interconnecter et en allemagne aussi à
mon avis
de quel pays qu'on parle
pour lutter contre la corruption il faut
avoir la justice indépendante la presse
libre
capable de poser des questions a
parfois des indésirables des
organisations commerciales qui veut
peuvent mettre mal à l'aise aussi la
lutte contre la corruption
doit être menée par des gens qui eux
mêmes respecte de façon irréprochable la
loi c'est une condition sine qua non
pour que cette lutte soit efficace
merci rachète day posez votre question
s'il vous plaît
bonjour dmitri smirnov à château-d'oex
sur le fond de ce qui se passe un
organiste a maintenant comment
évaluez-vous les résultats de
l'opération américaine de 20 ans et de
ses ailes dehors de leurs alliés peut-on
dire que c'est un échec total et cela
sera-t-il un prétexte pour revoir la
proche collectif de l'occident vers le
processus de la démocratisation
de deshors des pays tiers et encore une
question ou une demande plutôt pour
madame la chancelière
vous êtes probablement au courant du
fait que maintenant
vachette des en allemand se prépare à
son lancement mais malheureusement les
autorités allemandes font des obstacles
d'abord les banques les banques
allemandes ont reçu les recommandations
de fermer tous les comptes de
du groupe rtl maintenant les autorités
allemandes il s'agit des informations
ouvertes des médias allemands maintenant
il faut pression sur les forces au sein
bourgeoise pour qu'il
nous aide pas madame la chancelière
aidez nous à de promouvoir la liberté de
parole
ont ce qui concerne l'opération en
afghanistan
évidemment c'est du style de la
qualifiée de réussie mais ici on piétine
un petit peu sur ce point
sur cette question
est
difficile aussi de parler d'un échec
c'est un peu difficile ce qui est
important aussi c'est de parvenir à la
stabilisation dans le pays et je pense
que beaucoup de responsables politiques
en occident
commencent à prendre conscience de ce
dont j'ai parlé dans mon mot
d'introduction c'est à dire qu'il ne
faut pas imposer de l'extérieur des
standards de mode de vie à d'autres
peuples et d'autres cultures
sans prendre en compte les
particularités
culturelles ethniques historique
religieuse et je pense que cette prise
de conscience
doit se faire et doit servir de guide
pour mener une politique qui soit
réaliste nous avons vu ce qui s'est
passé dans la période du printemps arabe
et aujourd'hui ce qui se passe en
afghanistan et je pense que nos
cette volonté d'universalisme imposées
par nos partenaires occidentaux fait que
aujourd'hui on comprend que il y a quand
même respecter ces peuples et leur
accorder le droit
de disposer d'eux mêmes
ils ont parcouru ce long chemin de
démocratisation dans ces pays et
que ça nous plaise ou pas ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur je pense qu'il faut
construire des relations de bon
voisinage
dans le respect des
intérêts
sur le plan international et cette leçon
de l'afghanistan avec d'autres
partenaires avec les états unis les pays
européens nous la russie nous devons
qu'irait donc une leçon et travaillent
ensemble de façon à favoriser la
normalisation dans le pays et établir de
bonnes relations de voisinage avec lui
ce qui concerne l'afghanistan
je voudrais vous rappeler de notre point
du point de départ à les actes
terroristes du 11 septembre il y à onze
ans
en 2000 ans en 2001 les l'afghanistan a
fait des
actes terroristes les attentats et ce
qui a donné lieu à une lutte contre le
terrorisme et à l'opération de l'otan
qui a eu lieu
le terrorisme en afghanistan
c'est une question qui a été
amélioré avec le temps
mais la société
devrait lutter contre le terrorisme et
en afghanistan
en ce qui concerne un autre projet
la position générale du peuple afghan
sur son propre avenir là nous n'avons
pas atteindre un objectif et je le dis
ouvertement en décembre 2001
le ministre des affaires étrangères
fischer a convenu une conférence avec
tous les représentants d'un gué me sens
à pittsburgh
et il assuré il appelait les indiens à
trouver une solution commune
nous n'avons pas voulu imposer notre
position aux arguant nous avons vu que
des millions des filles était heureuse
de pouvoir aller aux écoles que les
femmes pouvaient avoir le droit à vivre
leur vie et la situation actuelle
afflige beaucoup de personnes maintenant
les talibans ont reçu plus de soutien
contre union pas et il faut quand même
essayer de sauver ceux dont la vie sous
une menace
des personnes qui n'ont pas pu quitter
le pays et pour que nous puissions
continuer à notre travail
qu'il s'agisse de la lutte contre la
polio ou d'autres sujets clés si nous
parvenons à voir des progrès dans ses
s'il n'y a pas de progrès dans ces
sujets là ce serait déplorable j'espère
que nous pourrons trouver des structures
il ya lesquels l'afghanistan pourra
trouver sa propre voie et dans le même
temps nous ne serons pas face à une
menace de terrorisme international en ce
qui concerne rt l'allemagne ne fait
aucune pression sur bruxelles
et sur les décisions et que bruxelles la
prends
ni le gouvernement fédéral ni ceux des
landais ne s'occupe de ces choses-là
choses là en allemagne
cdf
madame la chancelière les accords de
minsk existe depuis 6 ans déjà mais
l'ukraine est toujours divisé
les gens sont en train de mourir sur la
ligne de contact dans le donbass
y at-il des projets concrets après vos
négociations d'aujourd'hui concernant
les
nouveau tour de négociations au niveau
des chefs d'état et de gouvernement ou
bien le format normand a connu un échec
mais ce putin ma question pour vous une
fois nord stream 2 h 20 il y aura t'il
le transit via l'ukraine et si oui
est-ce que ça va continuer une fois que
madame a marqué
partira de kiev concernant les accords
de miss ne vont pas atteint les
objectifs que nous nous sommes fixés
mais c'est un format que nous avons et
qui inclut le groupe de contact
tripartite de négation nous avons des
négociations avec les séparatistes dans
les régions de donetsk de lougansk
il faut
prendre soin être précautionneux il
s'agit de ce format il faut le préserver
et si nous
déboucherons sur un agenda nous pourrons
nous mettre d'accord pour avoir des
négociations au plus haut niveau mais il
faut savoir de quoi discuter dans le
cadre de ma visite en ukraine je vais me
prononcer pour trouver un tel agenda
parce que même le moindre progrès
pourraient être décisifs c'est une tâche
très ambitieuse et très difficile à la
fois
il ya plusieurs facteurs différents et
je recommande donc
de
garder ce format même si
les choses n'avancent pas aussi
rapidement qu'on voudrait mais il faut
pas à laisser aller dans l'impasse je
suis d'accord avec madame la chancelière
à propos de
des accords de minsk et due forme en
normandie il n'y a pas d'autres
modalités pour discuter et trouver une
solution il faut respecter cette
situation
et même si nous n'avons pas encore
réussi à
faire ce règlement il ya encore les
résolutions du coup de l'onu qui ont été
adoptées et je pense que justement les
accords de misc ont acquis le statut de
textes de droit international nous
sommes préoccupés par le fait que
les autorités ukrainiennes publiquement
face à la presse dit certaines choses à
l'international et on en interne disent
d'autres autre chose donc et en gros ça
se résume à dire qu'ils ne vont pas
respecter les accords de musc
aujourd'hui j'ai informé madame la
chancelière du fait que le un nouveau
projet de loi a été proposé par le
gouvernement ukrainien et si cette loi
est adoptée ça signifie que et ce n'est
pas un secret c'est tout à fait
accessible c'est sur leur site ça
signifie que le cren va se retirer du
processus de minsk
s'est pas seulement qu'il ya une
contradiction avec ces accords 2000
c'est à dire ça va directement à
l'encontre de c'est un retrait de cet
accord de la part de l'ukraine et
j'espère que madame la chancelière
allemande au cours de ces discussions
pourra exercer une certaine influence
sur les autorités ukrainiennes pour que
cette loi ne soit pas adoptée en ce qui
concerne le transit de gaz
comme l'a dit madame la chancelière elle
a toujours tenu cette position et je le
soutiens et au cours de la construction
qui s'achève actuellement
je retire s 44 km 45 alexei comme un 15
km et il reste 15 km on peut considérer
que c'est quasiment terminée mais madame
la chancelière a toujours posé la
question de la poursuite du transit via
le territoire de l'ukraine même après
l'achèvement
l'expiration du contrat sur ce sujet
aujourd'hui cette question a été abordée
encore une fois pas la chancelière
aujourd'hui et je lui ai assuré que nous
respecterons toutes nos obligations en
matière de transit même une fois qu'elle
aura quitté son poste de chancelière la
russie va honorer tous ses engagements
nous le font et nous le faisons nous le
faisons et nous le ferons
nord stream 2 chacun dise que c'est un
processus que c'est une c'est une erreur
ou c'est une tentative de
tromper les gens au contraire c'est un
système moderne écologique ce ne sont
pas des paroles en l'air c'est un
système qui permet de réduire par 5 de
diminuer par cinq les rejets dans l'air
pour le transfert de ressources
d'énergie et nous devons tous le savoir
est le comprends c'est bien moins cher
que le transit par le canal ukrainien et
nous sommes prêts je le respecte encore
une fois je le dis je les dis
publiquement mais je le répète et après
2024 nous sommes prêts à poursuivre le
transit mais ne devons comprendre
dans quel volume pour quel délai et il
nous faut une réponse de la part de nos
partenaires européens qu'elle son volume
qu'ils sont prêts à acheter nous ne
pouvons pas signer des contrats de
transit si il n'y a pas de contrat de
débouchés de l'autre côté avec nos
partenaires
surtout avec l'ordre du jour l'agenda
vert qui est en cours de réalisation en
noble est ce qu'on va nous acheter notre
gaz et combien dont ça c'est une
question qui se pose donc là c'est un
homme une problématique de caractère
strictement
commerciales mais encore une fois nous
sommes tout à fait prêts à discuter nous
sommes tout à fait prêts à cela
notamment ce qui concerne pour les
livraisons les ce qui concerne les
livraisons pour l'europe du sud
et j'espère que dans l'année qui vient
nous aurons des sources
plus sûr de livraison pour les
consommateurs allemands que la russie
mais pour l'instant ce n'est pas le cas
merci la question finale interfax
vladimir poutine madame merkel pendant
ces années vous avez eu des contacts
intenses beaucoup de réunions et
discussions au téléphone dans l'espace
de ce ces années il y a eu des moments
positifs et négatifs dans l'histoire de
vos relations mais comment évaluez-vous
les résultats de ces années et comment
voyez-vous les perspectives des
relations russo allemandes dans l'avenir
je dirais que la question n'est pas très
correct je n'ai pas à juger le travail
de la chanson allemande c'est le au
peuplement de le faire et il va le faire
justement dans des élections
législatives prochaines au bundestag
en tout cas les relations
ont évolué de façon diverse nous l'avons
souligné nous avons différentes
approches vis-à-vis de telle ou telle
question mais il néanmoins le volume de
notre coopération malgré toutes les
difficultés en dépit de tous les
obstacles il n'a fait qu'augmenter
il est beaucoup plus nourris
d'anciennes composante économique qui
est très importante
l'allemagne est notre deuxième
partenaire économique
aujourd'hui après la chaîne
c'est 70 milliards de dollars de change
annuel nous avons investi en allemagne
7,5 milliards ou même deux
2,5
alors que nos partenaires allemands ont
investi 18 milliards en russie d'où
évidemment
en matière dans le secteur industriel
évidemment c'est une c'est un vecteur
importante important est aujourd'hui
avec la chancelière nous avons abordé
des questions tout à fait concrète sur
de façon à satisfaire les milieux
d'affaires allemands en russie c'est la
solution des questions courantes mais
dans l'ensemble le volume et la qualité
de nos échanges ont
ont considérablement augmenté c'est tout
à fait positif et je suis je tiens à
dire que j'espère que après les
élections d'allemagne cette tendance se
maintiendra
je suis persuadé
que malgré les
différences des systèmes politiques il
faut garder les moyens de connexion de
communication il faut échanger ses
opinions
nous le voyons dans les relations
historiques entre l'allemagne et la
russie qui sont très variés
ces relations ont connu des moments très
très mauvais et des moments très positif
lors de ma présence au poste de
chancelière non le système politique ont
connu en développement dans direction
différente il y a donc un an groupe de
sujets critiques
nous avons toujours
su garder ce moyen de communication
j'espère que j'ai pu apporter ma
contribution dans ce sens et ce n'est
pas une option de ne pas avoir de
dialogue
merci jeune femme